[Musique]
glander oui bien sûr ridicule vraiment
je change de métier revient trop dur
peut pas continuer comme ça vous savez
qu'avec la fragilité de bovins bull vers
diack à mme colle est un facteur
aggravant et c'est pas parce qu'il a
écrit médoc sur certaines étiquettes que
ça vous soigner de quelque chose
je passais pour m'inscrire un de vos
ateliers de dégustation c'est confirmé
oui je dis oui ma pierre temps ce mois
c'est jacques vous allez la pécho se
voit pas bien vous vous pouvez m'appeler
artense moi c'est fini la wii
une dégustation se déroule toujours en
trois étapes l'aspect visuel
ensuite on va sentir le vin et après on
le goûte peu comme avec une femme alors
non pas vraiment
[Musique]
tout va bien j'ai ri p
c'est un peu idiot anderson j'ai
l'impression de tout connaître depuis
super longtemps je rêve d'avoir un
enfant alors je me mets à vouloir aller
plus vite que la musique voilà vraiment
un peu trop vite moi je peux pas
m'occuper d'un ghost
toi aussi tu as perdu quelqu'un de cher
[Musique]
pour la vie est un peu trop grise
ça fait du bien un petit coup de rouge
[Musique]
elle est comment très gâteau un sang du
christ aille bien
[Musique]